it's too hot out here first t-shirt day
of the year
word is the rivers been moving upstream
of me so I'm expecting today sometime
today maybe as late as early tomorrow
morning but not a lot of time to get the
last finishing touches done here it's
kind of nice to know that it is moving
it has put some urgency into what I'm
doing I know there's still some projects
that need to get done and and I got a
kick butt and get them done right now
because I know it's coming so the job at
hand right now is to get these logs all
tied together this is about two weeks
worth of cutting trees and hauling trees
in and this will all be raw materials
for use with my sawmill the big fear I
have is I got a little hell of a lot of
work invested in these logs and I don't
want them to float away so I think what
I want to try and do is get get some
nails driven into these run rope around
them connect them all up get them tied
off to a tree or something so they can't
float away and then I'll do the same
with that pile over there
in 2009 I had enough logs to build a
house and they all went away in about 12
hours that was a hard lesson learned so
I don't want to lose these it's pretty
hard to put a value on stuff like this
but you know this is thousands of
dollars worth of lumber I know that for
me it's the time I put into it
time and calories
so I need to do now is just take a line
staple it onto all the logs go back over
staple it up the other way that should
tie them together
one of the projects I have for this
summer in addition to finishing this
house is putting up a couple of yurts
one of them will be one that'll be for
my clients but the other one will be
basically a workshop 24 foot diameter
workshop so I have a good place to work
in the winter you don't usually get
trees this big
I had to hunt around quite a while to
find trees this big around here pretty
valuable these big guys right here are
pretty valuable to me I don't want to
lose them
no if that'll stop it from floating away
or not but maybe there's a little bit of
peace of mind that it might slow it down
anyway I think if I fled to the point
where all these logs are floating and
all this material here is floating I'm
in big trouble I'll probably have a lot
bigger worries than a few logs floating
away at that point I think that's good
you